kolo gistau madame la présidente eliane
assassi
[Applaudissements]
avec le sourire
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs les
ministres à madame la première ministre
la france vit une situation politique
inédite pour la première fois dans le
cadre du quinquennat un président de la
république et son gouvernement ne
dispose pas du soutien d'une majorité
absolue à l'assemblée nationale pour la
première fois depuis trente ans un
gouvernement s'apprête à agir sur le
sens la confiance des parlementaires
comment emmanuel macron en est-il arrivé
là tout d'abord les élections en 2017 et
2022 sont le résultat non pas d'une
adhésion à un programme mais contre
l'extrême droite le chef de l'état nie
l'évidence le 22 juin il atteignait même
que son élection s'est faite sur le site
sur le fondement d'un projet clair en me
donnant une légitimité clair or l'étape
nouvelles de la crise institutionnelle
que nous vivons puise sa source dans un
hiatus démocratique évident
emmanuel macron a vaincu madame le pen
grâce à l'électorat de gauche celui de
la droite lui étant déjà acquis dès le
premier tour et des millions d'électeurs
ont fait le choix de l'abstention
à l'évidence il faut imaginer un nouveau
régime parlementaire véritablement
ouvert aux citoyens en effet nous en
nous sommes arrivés là car ce qui est
rejeté aujourd'hui outre un bilan sur
lequel je reviendrai c'est la
verticalité d'un pouvoir méprisant d'une
dérive monarchique
emmanuel macron a failli dans l'exercice
démocratique du pouvoir et il a été
sanctionné en conséquence je le répète
il n'a pas de majorité absolue à
l'assemblée nationale enfin une raison
fondamentale a conduit à la crise que
nous connaissons
durant ces cinq années le président a
été perçu comme celui des riches parce
qu'il l'a été les chiffres sont là un
seul exemple en 2021 les salariés des
pdg du cac 40 on prête que les salaires
des pdg du cac 40 ont presque doublé
doit se faire le point sur l'explosion
des dividendes ou du maintien malgré
toutes les belles déclarations
gouvernementales de l'évasion fiscale au
niveau de 80 à 100 milliards d'euros par
an soit près du double du budget annuel
de l'éducation nationale le
ruissellement n'a pas eu lieu les
salaires ou au mieux stagner le plus
urgent est temps pour vous de supprimer
l'impôt sur la fortune mobilière la flat
tax n'hésite pas tous ont pu poursuivre
leur belle vie petits arrangements
fiscaux bien au chaud dans le nid
douillet de la macro ni le en même temps
aurait dû entraîner une amélioration de
la vie des salariés les plus beaux et
les plus pauvres que nenni casse du
droit du travail par les ordonnances
pénicaud bay les apl mise en cause des
droits des chômeurs par votre projet
madame la première ministre
accélération de la libéralisation du
transport ferroviaire contredisant son
essor écologique après la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
ce sont des milliers de chômeurs en
moins qui ont été indemnisées puisqu'il
faut avoir travaillé au moins six mois
et non plus quatre pour être prises en
charge il s'agit d'une réforme honteuse
alors que les actionnaires et financiers
de tout poil sont gressèque vous avez
appauvrit les chômeurs nous savons que
durant la crise de l'aco vie de la
nation toute entière a fait un grand
effort pour permettre à notre pays à son
économie de passer l'épreuve ce que nous
avons pu constater aussi c'est que les
moyens existent est pour agir la
mobilisation financière qui a été
possible face à la copie doit être
renouvelée pour faire face à l'urgence
sociale éducative et écologique les
comptes d'apothicaire ne sont plus de
mise oui il est temps d'agir pour
redresser notre pays pour tracer un
avenir
votre projet sur le pouvoir d'achat
n'est pas à la hauteur des besoins il ne
permettra pas de relancer la mécanique
économique pour la consommation il ne
répondra pas à la détresse de millions
de nos compatriotes
l'inflation galope porté par une
spéculation indigne il faut d'urgence
bloquer les prix des produits de
première nécessité et baisser le prix de
l'énergie carburant électricité et gaz
l'échec ça suffit 100 euros par 650
euros par là peuvent donner l'illusion
d'une aide comment imaginer qu'une au
monde 200 euros pour les étudiants en
difficulté leur permettra de se loger de
se nourrir d'acheter leur matériel il
faut une véritable allocation étudiante
2000 53 euros par mois comme nous le
proposons a donc avec nos amis de la
nuque plus généralement il faut
augmenter les pensions et les salaires
c'est ça madame la première mini ce la
clé d'une amélioration réelle et pérenne
de la situation le smic à 1500 euros
n'est tout de suite est une nécessité
absolue pour des milliers de salariés
c'est le gouvernement qui peut donner le
la en matière salariale en augmentant le
smic qui par un effet domino entraînera
une augmentation générale des salaires
qu'est ce qui bloque
madame la première ministre qu'est ce
qui bloque le patronat le cac 40 la
situation politique
le signal fort envoyé par les électeurs
exigent que ce soit l'intérêt général
qui prime et pas l'intérêt de ceux qui
détiennent le pouvoir de l'argent il
faut immédiatement convoqué une
conférence nationale sur les salaires le
capital doit re trible rétribuer
dignement le travail agir pour le peuple
dans l'intérêt du peuple en écoutant le
peuple ce n'est certainement pas en
retardant l'âge de départ à la retraite
là aussi emmanuel macron s'il persiste
ne respecterait pas la volonté des
électeurs ils n'ont pas à voter pour
cette mesure comme il ne l'avait pas
fait en 2017 il exige au contraire la
retraite à 60 ans agir
ce ne peut être mettre au travail des
bénéficiaires du rsa agir ce ne peut pas
ça ne peut pas être baisser les impôts
surtout pour les patrons avec une peine
baisse programmée de 7 milliards d impôt
de production mais tend d'ailleurs à mal
les finances des collectivités locales
par la suppression de la cvae ces
dernières dans l'hexagone comme en
outre-mer sont en première ligne face à
la crise sociale il faut compenser la
hausse du coût de l'énergie qui grèvent
leurs budgets de même l'augmentation
pleinement justifiée mais pour autant
encore trop faible des fonctionnaires
territoriaux doit leur être compensée
faute de quoi le service public en
pâtira agir pour le pouvoir d'achat
c'est geler les loyers pour ceux qui ne
passent plus les payer le logement doit
redéfinir devenir une grande cause
nationale et nous tenons à votre
disposition une ppl précise sur ce sujet
l'accès aux soins doit être une priorité
cessé de suivre les recommandations des
cabinets de conseil comme mckinsey et
capgemini
l'épidémie de coville a mis en évidence
la crise de notre système de santé à
l'hôpital et en ehpad ce qui exige de
les soustraire à la loi du marché alors
que la septième vague est là allez-vous
agir informer recruter équipés allez
vous construire payés dignement pour
casser la désertification médicale
allez vous assurez un remboursement dit
en commençant par appliquer réellement
le 100 %
l'éducation nationale est elle aussi en
danger il manque trois mille postes pour
la rentrée un exemple pour décrire la
situation
426 professeurs d'école admis dans
l'académie de versailles pour
1430 à pourvoir un effort financier
considérable doit être engagé le
développement du service public de
l'enseignement transport de la police à
l'hôpital en dépend cet effort financier
sera nécessaire pour une politique
industrielle et agricole fondée sur
l'hérault leur localisation et le
respect de la planète en si peu de temps
il n'est pas possible de nous et de nous
de vous répondre sur tous les points
dans la première ministre votre logiciel
de régression sociale et de casey
services publics annoncés le peuple n'en
veut pas nous n'avons pas d'illusions la
réalité politique pousse votre
gouvernement vers la droite des
hémicycles et depuis cinq ans
la majorité sénatoriale a très souvent
soutenu les poussée libérale de monsieur
macron votre projet sur les retraites
par exemple aucun trac obtiendra à coup
sûr son soutien madame la première
ministre nous disons aussi attention à
toute tentative d'un jeu mortifère avec
le rassemblement national qui tourne
toujours et encore le dos à l'idée même
de progrès oui madame la première
ministre nous serons vigilants pour que
notre peuple soient préservés de la
violence libéral et de la haine et nous
porterons en permanence avec les députés
de la nuque l'espoir de progrès de
justice sociale et d'une transition
énergétique d'une urgence évidente en
somme nous opposerons à votre logiciel
libéral un logiciel de programmes de
transformation pour véritablement
répondre aux exigences populaires merci
madame la présidente
[Musique]